okay we are live streaming on YouTube
just wait for the confirmation of that
it will take a few minutes to go through
Richard okay it's about four or five
minutes okay I'll make sure and I'll let
you know when when I know that is there
okay thank you showed on my screen that
we're live
and the meetings now live on YouTube so
you can thank you very much good morning
this is a standards meeting of team
bridge district council I am councillor
Richard Keeling chairman of this
committee present our council Petric
present
councillor Hannes present council apart
I think we've lost connection with
counselor pert okay okay okay
cat counselor chairman would you like me
would you like to pause the meeting
cycles because obviously if he doesn't
hit any of debate he won't be able to
take part and their decision-making
process so would you like to pause while
I try and get back hold of them to see
if you can get into the meeting yes
please thank okay okay cancer leukemia
you can continue with the introduction
and I will get hold of him immediately
yeah I can actually see counselor pert
on the screen so counselor pert your
present please indicate present thank
you and counsel Nuttall isn't thank you
also present are the independent persons
counselor doors counselor Malone and
counselor doors witness will come in
later officers present are the
monitoring officer deputy monitoring
officer democratic services lead and
democratic officer also present is the
investigator the reason for this meeting
is for the committee to consider the
investigators report which counselors
have ready all 57 pages and for
transparency I have requested it to be
published on the TDC website with this
agenda that has been done
this hearing is regarding alleged
breaches by district council doors of
the counselors Code of Conduct this
committee and council polls the highest
standard set in relation to common
courtesy to the officers of this council
all counselors attended induction
training which includes the code of
conduct I move now to the agenda
item 1 apologies for absence I note that
council Bullivant is not present as he
has a personal interest arising from
councillor doors having made a complaint
about him I move on to item 2
declaration of interests do I have any
declarations of interest councillors I
see none thank you
item 3 can I remind councillors to
direct all questions and comments
through the Chairman and after speaking
use their mute button I now ask the
investigator to give a brief
introduction of the report please thank
you thank you chairman this
investigation was initiated by the
monitoring officer in response to
concerns expressed by members and
officers about the conduct of councilor
doors happened another councillor the
concerns were categorized into three
general areas and within this framework
I thought to identify the specific
instances of conduct which were of
concern and exactly what they entailed
in the case of councillor doors
I considered five instances of conducts
these were his actions in relation to
the Newton says no website an email he
sent on the 18th of June his visit to
the managing directors office on the
24th of September a Facebook post he
made on the 24th of September and an
email he sent on the 21st of October in
section 5 I've set out my findings of
fact many of these are undisputed or a
matter of record I've considered matters
which were disputed and have come to
conclusions on these on the basis of my
findings of fact I assessed councillor
doors is conduct in relation to the
council's code of conduct
and I deal with the five instances in
turn in Section six regarding the mutant
says no website I found that any actions
of councillor doors took place before he
was elected he was acting in his private
capacity and the code of conduct was not
applicable to him he did not therefore
fail to follow the code in his email to
the managing director of 18th of June
councillor doors challenged the housing
configures used in the local plan he
claimed that the managing directors
defense of the housing numbers was
tantamount to misfeasance in public
office to suggest this publicly is a
serious accusation it implies that the
managing director acted legally and did
so knowingly and wilfully I found very
little justification for the accusation
of misfeasance the managing director was
not personally responsible for preparing
the house and figures planning officers
from team bridge other Devon councils
and external consultants undertook this
task the figures were scrutinized and
challenged throughout the Local Plan
process they were examined again in the
public inquiry and they were found to be
reasonable I consider the councillor
doors his accusation of misfeasance
against the managing director was
misplaced and unjustified it criticized
his integrity and was damaging to his
standing I found therefore the
councillor Dawes was disrespectful to
the managing director and therefore
failed to follow paragraph 4 1 of the
code of conduct
prior to his visit to the Managing
Directors office on the 24th of
September councillor doors had been
arguing for the climate change briefings
to be open to the public he had been
told that it was impractical to change
the arrangements of short-notice
illegal of precipitant to him
the briefing was not subject to the
public access provisions of the Local
Government Act 1972 on the morning of
the briefing councilor doors arrived at
the managing directors office without
notice
effectively demanding to be seen he
interrupted the meeting with councilor
comment without acknowledging him or
apologizing for doing so
councillor doors argued with the
managing director and warned him that he
was on finised trying to run the council
his manner in the exchange was rude and
aggressive I consider that by arriving
without noticed and requiring to be seen
by interrupting the meeting and by
arguing rudely and aggressively
councillor doors was disrespectful to
the managing director and counts the
comment he therefore failed to follow
paragraph four one of the code I
consider the camp's for doors is warning
to the managing director was suggesting
that his job would be under threat this
was a threatening and intimidating he
therefore failed to follow paragraph
four two of the code these actions built
upon councilor doors is refusal to
accept a reasonable explanation and
legal advice about public access to the
members briefing they were combined
within bringing two members of the
public into the council offices in
breach of security arrangements and
directing one of them to the Managing
Directors office when this episode is
viewed as a whole I believe an objective
observer would consider that council
adores his approach was inappropriate
and diminished probably confidence in
the way he carried out his role I
consider the counter doors
brought his office as a counsellor into
disrepute and therefore failed to follow
paragraph four seven of the trade
councillor doors his Facebook post of
the 24th of September followed the
climate change briefing he criticized
the local plan and roads we have always
fell
the management of TDC was out of control
in doing so counselor doors were saying
that counts the counselor managers are
acting contrary to political direction
and against the plans and policies of
the council he groped that his request
for public access for the to the
briefing had been flatly refused with no
good reasons given he stated that this
was in clear contravention of the Local
Government Act this was simply not
correct there were legitimate reasons
for not changing the arrangements for
the briefing and these have been
explained to councilor doors a legal
officer had confirmed that them that the
briefing was not required to be open to
the public
I found that counselor doors is claimed
in his post were inaccurate and
unjustified they were disrespectful and
damaging to the managing director and
his management team he therefore failed
to follow paragraph four one of the code
of conduct in his email of the 21st of
October councillor doors expressed
concern that the local plan review was
running behind schedule
he wrote that this was because the job
was not done properly in the first place
I concluded that councillor doors views
about the progress of the local plan
review were legitimate his comment on
the cause of the delay referred to the
council in general it was not
disrespectful to any individual or group
I found therefore the counts the doors
did not fail to follow the code of
conduct in this state email I considered
that the council's protocol on member
officer relations was relevant to this
investigation the fundamental principle
of that protocol is that members and
officers should treat each other with
courtesy at all times
I found that councillor doors failed to
treat officers of with respect in three
instances I found he was also
intimidating to the managing director in
one of those instances if followed as
therefore the can
the doors also fail to follow the
protocol in these instances
so in summary chair I found that
councillor doors failed to follow the
code of conduct in three key instances
and the details of these are set out in
section 7 of my report Thank You chair
thank you very much in in kikyo report
councillor doors has just indicated
prior to the meeting that he wished to
read a statement I will allow that but
given the caveat that it's pertaining to
this report and nothing else we need to
consider this and I will stop you
councillor doors if you detract from
that please go ahead
councillor doors thank you Richard I
said that I'd only engage with this
process when it was in the public domain
it is now and I am engaging the
investigator just said that the report
was included elements that aren't
disputed that is not true I am now
engaging the record with the report I
will dispute much of the report we won
the election because we believe team
breach district councillor was out of
control than we said so since gaining
office suddenly that still remains our
view we've continued to say so but Karen
tricky presumably under the instruction
out the doors please
hello the doors please keep to the
report the investigation has been
carried out by $10 Liam um with no
formal investigates qualifications whose
councillor doors counselor doors I'm
sorry can i no don't Tobi's beat me
please can I just say to you that we're
considering the report here not the
person that has given the report and not
any other member of staff can you
refrain from that and continue to talk
about the report I will talk about the
report I'll talk about the basis of the
report we've carried out due diligence
on tenders in which the council refused
to do that due diligence has been sent
to all council members now it raises
some very serious questions about his
fitness to carry on counts the doors of
sleepless keep to the report it's not
about I tried
i microns microns can we get just to cut
in here I have sent Aldo speagle
out some alone I don't want to delete
you here or mute you I would like this
to be open can I just reiterate can I
just reiterate that we're here to listen
to the report and question that report
and we're going to do that when not
detracting from this so please keep to
that continue sir yes III agree I think
the residents the taxpayers and the
electorate would like to see annalistic
view of this of this case why it came
about and the basis it came about and
the suitability of the people to
investigate democratically elected
members I'll get on now to my crimes my
crimes were out the doors you dope there
is no crime okay the crime this would
have been sent to the police okay mine
is not a crime we're investigating
breaches of the code of conduct okay my
breaches of the code of conduct are
expressing an opinion than the
management of the council is out of
control
questioning the housing numbers in great
detail and going to fill shares office
and complaining that I and the leader of
the council with the full backing of the
executive believed members of the public
have been allowed to attend a briefing
on climate change
the single biggest issue of our time not
the revolutionary ants associates
testifies I knocked on the door he
invited me in I was not deliberately
rude or offensive I did not shout I did
not bang my fists on his desk
I did not pin mr. shears up against the
wall mr. Dursley knows this so for most
of the reports is is based on historical
description of noone says no of various
things other things have written in the
past about the council thus mr. Dursley
tries to paint noone says no as a
pantomime villain who deserves to be
punished even though there's no actual
substance to the investigation or any
direct relation to my role as a
counsellor in effect the investigation
scene
they want to buy me guilty by
association
furthermore the report is inadmissible
in its current form mr. Dursley
completed the report on the 5th of
February 20 26 months ago
it's be rather incomprehensible to a
person on the street than six months
later and less than 48 hours before this
hearing Phil shares added a statement
online that allege and the ledge record
of an interview with Alan comment from
the twenty from November 2019 for the
public record this statement in its
current form neither states the data it
was sent to the witness or that he
assigned it as an accurate record based
on mr. Dawson's the doors can I just
interrupt you there sir I have seen that
record as as all counselors have seen
that and I have spoken personally to
councillor Connick to affirm that that
report is clear and concise and correct
and he confirmed that and you know
counts laconic you can tell counselor
colleague something that isn't true and
lead him in a different direction which
you're trying to pertain to that's not
the case that report is very clear and
States fact rich chance that Connacht
and rich is a con it can I just finished
it councillor Connick has confirmed that
to me and I'm happy with that it's for
these counselors on this committee to
decide that not you sir
please carry on you know that no no call
would accept evidence at a late stage no
again I reply to you this is not a court
of law sir this is hearing Richard speak
please this is ridiculous opening
statement allow him to make a statement
no mother no other team bridge District
Council meeting would allow a simple
question less than five working days it
is ridiculous that six months after the
report is sent to me that I am hamstrung
I've been unable to gain any legal
advice have been enabled to scrutinize
and it's unreasonable for that inference
to be considered part of the record
councillor doors we'll take that on
board what you you have just said but
again I'll say it's up to this council
this committee to decide that is that
the end of your statement sir no castle
doors is at the end of your statement no
no carry on then
so in summary I'll be providing a full
rebuttal I have statements from
community groups have appreciated me
voicing their very real concerns about
the actions of teen Rouge District
Council
I've got robust red buttons against all
the vexatious charges the whole process
is further evidence and senior
management the team which District
Council a totally out of control many
elected members know this we have the
courage to say in public okay Thank You
councillor doors right if you could meet
yourself a moment sir because I've got
some background noise coming in counts
the doors yeah Thank You councillor
Malone can I just finish agenda item
three and then I'll come back to you
thank you I've seen your hand is up
the committee to consider the following
and its findings of fact section five I
will ask counts the doors to come in at
each paragraph and ask for his comments
and counselors can question council
doors or the investigator
before doing that counsel Malone do you
want to come in there
you got your blue hand up you have to
mute unmute yourself sir thank you
yeah I'm sorry but I I cannot see how
these sudden evidence from councillor
Cana is in any way admissible I mean
this this incident happened on the 24th
of September 2019 interviews were taken
by mr. Tousley in November
the final report done and dusted
apparently was published in February and
then 48 days later 292 days after the
incident suddenly this witness testimony
from counselor connot suddenly appears
now this let me speak please
appears absolutely ridiculous now
there's only a number of possible
explanations why it should suddenly
appear one is maybe you lost it
secondly perhaps councillor Connor
didn't want it used and has been leant
on or thirdly maybe it was taken at the
right time and submitted at the right
time but you would deliberately withheld
it from councillor doors thank you it's
terrifying to know isn't it if anyone
counts for Maloney of the former leader
of this council and of this council in
general that they only need to wait two
hundred and eight point five seven
working days to get that you know
excused counselor this committee will
consider I want you to add all I've
heard what your soul matches the
committee
now counsel Malone please we will take
everything into consideration and I am
listening to you
and what you've just said please take
down your blue hand sir so that we can
continue so I'll move on now to finding
a facts section five
and in the report five point eight to
five point two eight undisputed facts as
advised by the investigator capsular
doors do you have any comments on that
yes yes I do I do have comments on that
the well for the record there's been no
formal complaint raised against me when
the let's deal with their five point
eight to five point two eight please so
I five point eight to five point two
eight the the the point I would like to
make is that I did request Freedom of
Information request and subject as
access requests to be able to defend my
position team bridge District Council's
of failed in its obligation to supply
those if the doors this is this is
materials this I'm sorry the the council
has failed in its legal obligations that
it's been told demanded by the ICO to
provide he was told in February had to
provide given a now days and its ability
so it has findings of fact please right
is there any counselor wishing to I'm
sorry yours yes no counselor doors let
me continue please okay is there any
counselor that wishes to ask counselor
doors any questions on that or the
investigating officer I see no hand so
I'll move on no point to nine to five
point three six which are disputed facts
yes no wrench up doors we've dealt with
that one now oh no we haven't we've got
three points five point five five point
seven and five point nine I would they
will be in my rebuttal I'd like the
county committee to hear them now well
we're on five point two nine so just
hold back there five point two nine two
five point three six
these are disputed facts no no I'm I'm
on five point five the finding of facts
I'm countering those five point five I
will allow you to say that carry on it's
gone thank you so this is the I've also
considered whether the counselor was
acting in the role as a counselor in
their private life if they were not
acting in the role as a counselor the
code of conduct is not applicable I'd
like to confirm for the purpose of the
statement that you have no evidence that
I created or even but you weren't a
counselor we're not disputing this okay
what I want to know is why this whole
document is shrouded with things that
clearly have no representation or no
effect on my releases up to this
committee to decide this whether you
were acting as a counselor when my
complaints were made so myself it's not
relevant to the investigation why is it
in there okay I have a point on five
point seven five point seven and no five
point six sorry I just want to know if
I'm being joint and severally liable
held for the joini several million for
the actions of Liam alone I don't
understand why this no no no no
counselor doors we're dealing with
yourself today hold one second counselor
Linda and the questions I want to ask
her more around how the officers and the
managing director have been treated with
such a lack of respect the Facebook post
with the mr. shears and his daughter I'm
not sure how anybody can think that
that's that's is there for all the
public to see and I would like to know
what how they would feel if it was their
relative that was being put all over
Facebook like that and also the other
one that I that really concerned me in
in this world how it can make an officer
so frightened that she doesn't want to
go back to her own home so it's not just
about the local plan we were elected to
fight for I could stitch
I know I understand that's what this is
in cancer stores report so I'm asking
the question because it's in the report
but it's also it's not just about the
plan it's also about how you treat
individuals and as counselors we are
expected to treat officers with respect
if we don't like what they're doing we
should still be able to fight our case
with respect could I come back to that
point that question can you can actually
that question is aimed at you counselor
doors yeah yeah okay no thank thanks for
the question because I actually sums up
totally and perfectly why is his flawed
to have that post about Phil shears and
his daughter in my report why is his
flawed to have a case relating to Mia
Malone in my report they've been put in
there as smears the Chairman will will
verify other than the fact that there's
no proof that I wrote it had any
responsibility for it or what even my
view on that post on field shears and
his daughter raised but but the chairman
will clarify it has no bearing and no
relevance on my conduct as a counselor
it was posted before anyone from Newman
says no was elected there's no proof
that I wrote it it's been put in my
report to discredit me Tim Donnelly
knows that it has nothing to do with me
and there has nothing to do with my
conduct as a counselor the yeah yes yeah
that's a very very good point thank you
for raising them that behavior towards
the planning officer in a post by Liam
Malone I would like to question very
seriously why that is in my report it
has been put in my report to discredit
me it has nothing to do with my conduct
as a counselor counselor doors thank you
almost as if you can counsel Malone if
you wait
again I will I will mute you permanently
please allow people to speak this is
what this committee is about don't over
talk people disrespectful I'm going to
move on now to five point two nine to
five point three six disputed facts so
five point two nine to five point three
six is the NSN website five point three
seven to five point four one is the
email to fill shares of the 18th of June
as counselors we need to check clarify
the facts and be clear what if is any in
dispute between the investigator and the
counselor any questions on that
counselor Patrick you still have your
blue handout sorry counselor doors do
you wish to comment
yes 5.29 as kind of every one today the
Newton says no website is referenced in
my report I want to know why it's
reference in my report and why I'm being
held responsible for it and if it's
suggested that I wrote it did you sir no
I didn't okay thank you
moving on then I can see no hands up
five point four two two five one five
one three two as well okay fire away
handsome alone there's a mention of
counselor Malone doing something with
the website I want to know why that's in
my reports I'm not discussing counselor
Malone now no I know I agree as the
doors so could the committee question
why it's in my reports he's continually
managing committee will decide that as I
said five point four two to five point
six to read members briefing on climate
change 24th of September 2019 counselor
doors do you have any comments on that
I do have if you're just give me a
second scan show can I just go back to
five point two nine please chair
certainly far away
it's actually it's not quoting it's not
saying that it's cancer Malone that did
it it's actually asking a question it's
saying it's saying that cancer Malone
told him something so it's not anything
to do with what cancer Malone has done
he's actually quoting what he said to
him thank you okay again can I kick come
back on that cancer door yeah why is
what cancer Malone said relevance and my
conduct as a counselor from what I can
see it's because you've actually quoted
it cancer does in 5.29 it says I've
quoted it I'd like to bring the
investigator in please
thank you thank you sure I might be able
to help issues around the Newton says no
website it was one of the areas of
concern raised so I needed to look at at
that I needed to investigate it before I
could come to any conclusions about
whether it was official capacity or or
private capacity that's what I did
and by looking at the facts of the
circumstances I concluded that cancer
thought any any involvement he had there
was in his private capacity so the
investigation ends there really
counselor Malone's activities are in
part they're at simply as context for
what was happening
there's a there's a story to be told
about the background to this and some of
counsel and Malone's activities was part
of that story apart from that he's not
involved or implicated in this report
there's a separate report about about
his activities thanks very much
thank you for that I have indication
that councilor Haynes wishes to speak
and then counsel Malone thank you
Germany was on five point six zero and
five point
six-one but I don't know whether you've
got to them yet or not I just amount
that's the next moving on to and then we
went back so if you could ask me to
speak on those please yes certainly yes
no problem
council below you have your blue hand up
wishing to speak
you need to unmute yourself sir yes
sorry it's somewhat moved on from when I
had a point to make so carry on please
okay thank you
councillor Patrick you still have your
hand up nope
okay moving on to five point six three
to five point sorry I I haven't given my
points on five points for - thanks okay
please go ahead then so the the climate
change briefing they thought it'd been a
valuable for councillors to hear from
Exeter University which he bought it
would have been valuable for the public
and we had a lead time of six weeks I
haven't noticed the email which was
supplied to the committee members that
we were informed of it 14 days in
advance so continuously throughout the
record he says we we had six weeks
notice on council doors I I knew about
it six weeks before you did we all have
the same emails okay
now the calendar is quite clear I'll
challenge that because I have the email
I will supply its and members as please
yep yep Thank You council doors
okay can I move on so five point six
three point six far out I'm still on
five five point four five okay yeah
carry on council doors
yeah the briefing could be arranged in
private for members at the time of their
convenience and council the arrangements
have been notified six weeks in advance
I I came to that about a week before the
briefing council the doors requested
that the meeting be open to the public
he was given legal advice as and it was
an informal meeting and was not subject
to the access provisions of the Local
Government Act 1972 I I do not believe
that is cool
I the only communication that I've had
on the Local Government Act 1972 was in
an in an email on the first November
where I raised the complaints against
Phil shears for not allowing the public
in and that point only I was told that
it wasn't subject to it I have a full
email train of my request of the king of
the full executive backing my request
and of Gordon hook trying his hardest to
get people into the climate change
meeting - and no point did any member of
the Exeter of the management team give a
real reasonable justification why the
public were being excluded the the next
bullet points whilst the briefing could
have been arranged at the outset as the
public meeting the arrangements for it
would have been very different
with the issue being raised only days
before the meeting it was felt in
practical to arrange in short notice
only days is I'm afraid knowingly
misleading I read raised them counselor
doors we're here to you know look at
your conduct no sound how the council
works and within that venusian no I I'm
going to be Gerry on I'm going to be
judged on mine on this report in this
report said I raised there only days
before the meeting I have an email to
show that I was preparing the questions
for the full council meeting that
followed that council briefing and it
was at that point I thought it would be
very convenient for the public to come
to the meeting so I raised it seven days
in advance that does not to the eyes of
a normal reader relates at only days
okay if you can provide that that would
be fine yeah yeah I have counsel not oh
you wish to speak Thank You chair full
council hangs cattle dogs fur for your
information and for the record I do
think that our climate change briefing
should have been open to the public what
is in question today is your behavior in
reaction to the fact that it wasn't and
I'd like you pleased
talk us through why you let meant to
members of the public through the
security door we using your staff pass
and whether or not you feel that your
encounter with the managing director
will involved disrespectful and
insulting behavior yes we will get to
that we know that's a question directed
to you counselor doors if you could
answer that please okay so well we come
on three in all the points later on but
I will explain exactly what happened
many there were the email train it will
show that even at seven o'clock of the
evening before that there was still a
question of whether the climate briefing
was going speed no no the question to
you was from counsel Nuttall and he was
asking about your conduct yes about the
meeting my conduct my conduct is amazing
model on there were two people in
Trinity and and myself arrived at the
front door of team bridge District
Council and five to nine on the day of
the climate briefing we did stand and
knock on the front door to try to gain
access it was still unclear to me
whether the public gallery was open so I
said why don't we go and have a look so
I took these two females up to the
landing that is next to the public
gallery as many people all know the
landing next to the public gallery is
the area in front of the cafe which is a
public area so I took them there and
found the door was not I then said wait
here I'll go and check with the leader
of the council Gordon Hoke who told me
the day before he was doing everything
in his power to open the meeting to the
public so I then went through to the
secure area where the council offices
are and my personal she doesn't get me
in there so someone had to give me
access I stood my head round
Gordon hooks door and he said I'm sorry
I haven't been able to open it it's Phil
she has decision go and see him I then
went to Phil shears office which people
all know is a glass-fronted office
I knocked on the door Phil she has
looked up at me waved me in and then
started a conversation which was and how
can I help
I then asked him if the meeting on
climate change was going to be open to
the public
and he told me they're going to speak to
Sarah about that that I'd been told it
wasn't and I said that I thought it
should be based on the Local Government
Act 1972 and that not letting the public
in was an action that was was him
skating on thin ice it was his
responsibility to do that he we ended
the comment we didn't we agree to differ
we I argued the point I did not have an
argument those are two very different
things
and I then left as noted council the
comment was was in the meeting before I
entered the room it appeared that Phil
shears had acknowledged against the
comment comment that he was letting me
in the room he let me in the room I had
a conversation with him we had a debate
I argued a point he disagreed with me I
left I don't went back to public landing
and said to the two people I'm sorry
it's not going to be open one of the
individuals said whose decision is that
and I said it's the management director
Phil shears and she said where's his
office I said well it's in that secure
area through there my ass doesn't let
you in there I don't think you'll be
able to get in she then went in the
direction to try and ask him why it
wasn't open to the public and and then
the the other person left the building
and and I wasted a random went to
default council meeting okay counselor
doors Thank You councillor Haines Thank
You chairman it was on
five point six and and it relates to an
earlier point raised in the statement my
counsellor doors about the the text of
the statement I can't smoke on it are
you recently becoming available if we
look at five point six zero it says
counselor colleague described counselor
doors manner was rude and aggressive he
said it was more than assertive it was
disrespectful
now that text is what appears in the
record of the statement from counselor
connect that only got sent out more
recently so clearly the statement had
been made before the report was written
since it is actually word for word as is
in now so my question is given that
counselor door said you know he just
seen this statement from counselor
Connacht which of course we've only
recently seen this and we've only
recently seen the text of the whole
report given that it was the report was
sent to him some while ago and this
appeared in there my question is why
didn't he ask to see the full text of
counselor colet's interview at that time
I I assumed that the the investigator
have put together a full and robust
report and I assumed that the statement
and and testimony of Phil shears which
actually doesn't concur with counselor
comments at all he doesn't suggest that
I was aggressive he doesn't suggest that
I was I was threatening or disrespectful
and on that basis I was dealing with all
the information to hand I don't think
it's reasonable to expect me to to
suggest that a statement that has been
taken has been withheld and I should
know about it okay thank you can see
doors counselor perked
Thank You chair the question to cancel
the doors when you were elected in 2017
may you were given a copy of the code of
conduct did you ever read that code see
what was expected of you as a counselor
I was elected in May 2000 and 1990 yeah
yeah 2019 and yes I actually understand
the code of conduct and I surely
understand the responsibilities that I
hold to my Electra into the residence
and and yes I understand and accept it I
think it's the point of the
interpretation of whose very best
interest I should be acting in and and I
think there is a propensity for the
council to suppress scrutiny to suppress
you're going off again counselor doors
did I rip the code of conduct yes do I
treat people with respect yes I do in
everyday life and and anyone who knows
me would be able to verify that the the
point there isn't there is another very
good point as well about respect is
something that needs to be earned
rather than demanded and enforced okay
thank you counsel could I just have a
follow-up question on that yes certainly
but in your answer counselor doors you
fail to mention then members of staff or
other kuroh councillors only the
electorate in my could you quote the
line that I said I said what you
actually said that when you was elected
as far as I recollect you were
responsible to the electorate which is
true but you didn't mention the fact you
were also responsible to treat people
weaker to say not members of staff and
fellow councillors I think I would want
to say is I have responsibilities to my
electorate
I do not have responsibilities to the
management of team bridge district
counsel I work alongside them as I work
alongside people in my professional life
I work alongside counselors who I've
very strong ideological disagreements
with okay thank you
Thank You counselor doors could
counselors put down their blue hands
please those that don't wish to speak so
that I can see if somebody wants to
moving on five point six three to five
point six five reason a face I have my
hand up throughout there I have a okay
capsule Malone
joy here not as a witness you're hearing
counselor dawn general discussion that
we just yes what I'm sorry so we're
moving on no I'm sorry but we can that
needs to be made absolutely adores not
about yourselves can can I say my
understanding is that if I I was I was
asked if I wanted anyone in the hearing
to support me I have a witness that is
coming in on five point six eight six
point eight no on the documents please
stay is appropriate I want to be
representing or supported at the hearing
by another person yes if so set out the
name of the person constantly Malone
care of Ford house
I have asked Mia Malone here to support
me on that document it said he would be
able to support me I would like him to
be able to make a point in supported me
allow that if its brief counselor Malone
yes there's a very important point here
that I think we're skating over the
Local Government Act of nineteen seventy
two states that pub the public are
admitted to any meeting more or less as
a default for them not to be admitted
requires some robust reasons and Oman we
agree with you on those
reason given in this case said that they
weren't allowed in out it is irrelevant
what will be like what do you were
talking about is in that moment or do we
take the ruling of the law of the
country we live in
Thank You councilman law of the country
that we live in caps labor a lot is not
in the future the seed fat Council below
those you heard from councillor doors I
belong council below so I stopped
speaking take this all the way to the
top thank you is very robust you where
can I can I statement you're making
Thank You Council Malone
now can I state quite clearly it is the
wish of this council including those
elected members from the top down from
the leader down that we do involve the
public and we did question that that's
not what we're here for
we're here because of the counselor
Richard Dawes and his conduct that's why
we're here we're not talking about some
law for 1972 we all want democracy to
work and we all have like to fill Swiss
know you all have some alone or maybe if
you remember that sometimes Thank You
councillor Malone moving God counselor
doors have you finished
five point four two to five point six to
anything further sorry thank you
no no no I'm not saying you're finished
I'm say ninety all right is there any
other comments you wish to make oh yes
yeah five point five for in the the the
presentation of what my said to Phil
shears it says I said be careful Phil
because I think you're skating on thin
ice the use of the word be careful Phil
is a fabrication
I didn't say that I don't know where
that came from
yes the doors you've just said that you
did say it no yes I was reading the
document please don't try and tie us up
in knots just for clarity I did not say
the words be careful Phil if it is
written in my statements which I would
direct everyone to say I have not signed
as a true record of the interview with
with mr. Dursley unfortunately mr. Darcy
houses propensity to misrepresent what
has been said by witnesses the doors can
you then clarify what you did say I said
I think you're skating on thin ice
because you are in breach and this
council is in breach of the Local
Government Act 1972 I did not say the
word alligator fulfilled that sounds
like it's from an episode of EastEnders
right thank you
is that the end counselor doors on that
point it is yeah yeah okay now can we
move on five point six three two five
point six five read the Facebook post of
the 24th of September 2019 your comments
counselor doors
well the overarching comment of news has
no website again it's just putting there
to - for no no reason that's all there's
no there's no evidence and why pertains
to me as an individual or as a counselor
six point nine in his email at the 18th
of June critics we haven't got that far
yet two counts littles so which points
are on five point six three to five
point six five okay okay it's the
Facebook post of the 24th of September
2019
okay okay no comment no comment name
okay counsel at all you have your blue
hand up do you wish to speak no okay
does any member of the committee wish to
question actually counselor doors or the
investigator on that does not counsel
and so you have your blue hand up again
nope trying to put it down okay okay
moving on then finding as to compliance
with Code section six and the role of
committee is to determine whether there
has been a breach
so we've now moved to six point five six
point seven the Newton said no website
investigator states no breach of the
code so should not be any issue for
clarification any comments council doors
on that yes he should never have been in
the reports okay
I'd move on then to six point eight to
six point sixteen you have okay thank
you
so council doors this is your witness
yeah I guess this item if I can just
explain what this is about
this is read the email to Phil shares of
the 18th of June note to the there were
two witnesses due to be before us but I
note there is one I have a I have a
statement from the second week okay I'm
happy for you to read that after the
witnesses I mean would you like to
introduce the witness capsule doors so
the winning the background to it please
yes yeah yeah the the witness to the
challenging of the housing numbers for
the local plan is the former chair of
Evans Kurzweil Irish Council kevin eels
who
he will give his background of the chair
of the the castle from well certainly
from the time of 2012 until until before
I was elected he'd left when I was
elected and as I one of the main reasons
I was elected for the amber award was on
the basis that I would challenge the
local plan the basis of the housing
numbers and the housing numbers on going
so it was with great gusto and
incredible amount of detail that I then
went when elected put forward very long
very detailed and very very much back to
arguments why we thought and we used
that term to cover a lot of groups the
CPRA Devon the mobile residents
Association and habits codes where
parish council think the basis of the
housing numbers in their first instance
were misrepresenting the fact that they
were misrepresented is is is one point
the fact that that those bodies had
information to hand and put that forward
in a reasoned manner and would were
summarily ignored that is the point of
knowing luchadores
we're a little bit off track here I know
about yourself you asked me to introduce
ya but the bank going didn't you and
what I did is I started an email chain
which started with with one officer and
and I ended up in a conversation with
Phil shears and I put very detailed
arguments to - to the managing director
and within that within that conversation
it was the the view the view of a number
of people that not taking on board the
90 page document that was presented in
December 2012 & not engaging with the
groups with their well-founded world
based arguments was tantamount
turn to miss fee Anson public office and
that is a view that I still hold it's a
view to view but anyway I think we can
bring bring on kevin eels to to describe
his and mr. Kenton can mr. eels can you
hear me mr. eels would you like to amuse
self sir
okay can you hear me now yes I can thank
you sir
and and please go ahead okay thank you
very much and good morning chairman and
good morning to attendees and viewers
who's not into you my name is Kevin neon
sign that I served as an avid skiers
will perish Council for about ten years
and for many years I was the chair of
Abbott's Curzon parish council during
which time T DC's Local Plan was being
developed my personal career over 46
years was centered around ITN
information working for the Met Office
Ministry of Defence NHS ITN information
and latterly for an independent NHS
consultancy business I have held IT and
information posts at directorship level
at Aven Health Authority and provided
consultancy to ensure Health Authority
and Gloucestershire Health Authority
that's my background
thank you missiles and you know why
we're having this hearing today you're
you're clear on that
ah retaining two accounts the doors yes
yes yeah yes and you've been called as a
witness by Councillor doors yes thank
you
the hearing in part relates to a PC
zabis cos or parish councils objections
to TDC local plan and the parish
councils attempt to understand and then
and thus democratically influence
development of the local plan APC
accepted the local plan a dot adopted in
May 2014 but it has not accepted
methodologies that were used in its
production our concerns were formally
laid out in a pcs objections to degrees
to tDCS local plan which was a 98 page
document dated 18th
semper 2012 presenting a PC and Wilbur
residents associations issues with the
local plan the crux of a pcs early
contestation to the local plan was
simple and related back
sorry mistrials were pretty well aware
of of that if you could get to the to
the point are you in support of
councillor doors and do you have any
information on his conduct that's what
why we're here could could I just just
interject cuz I've seen the statement
it's it's just over a page of background
that then informs the position there is
has been pointed out this is a very
strong position to take and it cannot be
taken mine Lee I think we can listen to
a page and a half of text from a
counselor who over 10 years tried to put
forward reasoned arguments and was not
listened to it would be fairly fairly
laughable that at this juncture if he
was not listened to again no what I need
to do is find fact councillor doors and
in fact to do with these breaches
suppose it breaches and that's what we
need to find out so that's why I keep
coming back to what is this how is this
pertaining to this committee so I will
allow I will allow mistrials to carry on
and because I am very open and you know
transparent on this let's listen let's
listen okay carry on mr. Eagles yeah I
think it is important to hear a little
bit of the history particularly when it
relates to the statement tantamount to
miss Vasant in public office so thank
you for allowing me to continue but
there was a statement and this is I I
admit this is going back a little little
way in time to the external table a
strategic housing market assessment of
2007
and I just quote one one paragraph which
stated all figures from the household
survey presented in this report have
been grossed up to represent overall
population with the emphasis that I've
been grossed up to represent overall
population the statement the parent
current paragraph continues therefore
where the report discusses specific
numbers of households or talents it is
not the number of respondents that is
referred to but the number of households
they represent it is important to
understand that in the 2012 Israel I'm
going to stop you there I don't feel
that there is any relevance here as you
as a witness to this committee I I
questioned that and if you could get to
the point I will allow you another
minute or so but we'd really need to get
on we have a full agenda here can I just
at the point there that with due respect
this to be a very strong statement to
put forward I am providing him win this
to justify the basis it was put forward
and this us justify your conduct counsel
do I condone z remotely is putting
forward this statement and I'm giving
the basis of why I put forward the
statements I think I think it's totally
unreasonable not to let someone read out
page to give the background as to where
that statement came from well I will
give mistrials another minute and no
more Thank You mr. eels no disrespect
but we do need to get on sir okay I did
see the exchange between mr. Dores and
mr. shears and I I do I did pick out two
points and that was mr. shears letter
which he referred to the ONS population
this is in February 2012
151
thousand one hundred thirty days later
that sorry 30 working days later it was
a six week period passed a more robust
population data source was available to
planners and unfortunately it appears
that team which did not address this and
in fact a PCS view was that our
objections were dismissed without feet
feedback directly to a PC a serious
omission given the gravity of the change
in numbers after my retirement from the
parish council in my discussions with
district councillor Richard doors I
suggested to him that the process
regarding population metrics thus
determining a household need in
developing the local plan was tantamount
to misfeasance
in public office and I will send you
counselor Keenan I will send you a copy
of the document that I've produced
please do and I will share that yes and
I do that today yeah I will do that
immediately okay
can I just say that Wendy grace and
current chairman of Abbott's girls or
parish cans or has read this statement
and endorses and endorses the concludes
there in queue so as soon as that that's
what I'm saying at this point in time
and as soon as I finished I won't email
you the document Thank You mr. eels and
thank you for coming coming on and
speaking to us thank you very much
okay so we're on six point eight to six
point sixteen any further comments
councillor doors before I move on to
council I think you said you were as I
mentioned there was another witness
Stayman who couldn't make the oh yes yes
please read that so I haven't they again
sorry counselor barrack just give me a
minute yeah I have another one-page
letter from the wall the residents
Association and it's from from Chris
quartz who's the Secretary of the
water'll residents association 15th of
July 2020 the wall Verizon's association
was formed in 2010 as 300 member
residents in the world work and college
board area the WRA is constantly
challenged the local plan including
housing numbers biodiversity and
environmental issues the lack of counsel
produced master plans in the major
damage councillor doors how does this
pertain to your conduct so following the
local elections last year and that we
will send a copy of this because you're
asking me to cut short a one-page letter
no I I'm asking you how does this
pertain to your conduct again this is
relating to the statement that Miss
fencin public office and giving an
opinion from a Residents Association why
saying it is a reasonable person you
attend you sir should share this
document with us yes I will and come on
we should have had it before this
meeting well I did you know I did say
that we had I had two witnesses one
couldn't make it and I would read out
and letter from them and you did tell me
you don't I'm I'm happy as long as it
pertains your conduct sir
my contention in the standards report
that counsel at door was made a public
accusation against the managing director
of Miss fiends in public office makes
little sense as he claimed as the claim
appears to arose in a private email
further the accusation seems to be miss
reading deliberately or otherwise of the
actual statement either the investigator
failed to recognize that the email was
private or the recipient chose to make
the message public why in either case
the writer can hardly be challenged
for merely stating an opinion trying to
solace opinions expressed in private
emails would undermine the democratic
process the decision to publish this
private email exchange must be taken by
somebody and the Russian now behind the
decision needs to be examined I will
supply this email to everybody Thank You
cats the doors counselor Patrick you
wish to speak challenging the housing
numbers robustly is what is what we are
there to do for the people that elected
us and the local plan there was a group
of which you were part of councillor
doors where you often did robustly put
your point across and and we were a
group it is all councillors that make
these decisions on the local plan and I
just want to try and understand why that
excuses your behavior in the way you
spoke to mr. shares and the youth the
words that you use he is the MD he we
are the counselors that make the
decisions we worked on the local plan
group and we all seem to work quite well
together to come up with the policies
etc at the local plan I know the housing
numbers are going to be done at a
different time surely that's it's us as
counselors at doing we don't that
shouted offices and about what they
they've done when they haven't done it
we do it it's always so for me it's
about the respect that we show them and
why are you blaming him personally which
is how it's coming across question can
you count the doors yeah now that's a
very very good question and the you've
mentioned shouts at officers I didn't
shout officers I made a I'll send as an
appendix I'm going to send the full
email exchange that went on over
six-month and was very detailed very
methodical and I was representing it and
still represent the voices and opinions
of of residents who feel they have been
ignored they put forward very very
strong and robust and back to arguments
and that does put you in a position if
those are ignored in a manner that is
knowingly harmful then then you could
consider the the miss feelings in public
office as as being something that that
might be leveled at an individual I did
not shout it's the the local plan
conversation groups that you're talking
about are fine yes we come up with
policies about houses that wasn't the
debate that was being had at this time
and also the the electorate put me in a
position to actually challenge this and
I was doing my job and I was doing it
very methodically in masses of detail
with a huge amount of respect in a
private email string the claim is made
that I made a public accusation it is
simply not true
Thank You castle doors councillor Haynes
the Chairman is on that last point the
council doors made as to whether the
email was private or more public
I got an email I'll be formal you know I
I can take the point about the degree in
which it was not public but it was
copied apart and three members of Newton
says no it was copied also to the leader
of the council and the planning
portfolio holder so one of the things
that I would ask is to whether that is
considered my accounts the doors to be
private and it is also a question I
would need to ask our own legal advice
later on I presume Jim monkey pants the
doors that's certainly not public is it
and also the
I made a public accusation it is not an
accusation
it is stating my view okay thank you
very much counselor doors if no further
questions on that paragraph we will move
to 6.17 so when we finished 6.6 if we're
moving on to the next part the witness
will go back into the counsel Malone you
have your blue handout you wish to speak
yes I do
councilman can we see you on picture
there we are
yes my hands been out for quite a while
and so this pertains to something but
it's a general point I think it might be
useful to everyone before we got into
the Kevin heals his witness statement it
came up again the Newton says no website
can I just make a quick point that I
think will be useful for everyone in
considering the Newton says no website
all right I just like to make it clear
it was set up by me it was not set up by
Richard doors it had 12 or 13
contributors I cannot remember Richard
doors contributing anything to it and so
I'm not sure why he is mentioned in this
it was actually a conduit by which I met
Richard doors I didn't know him before
and what it was was the means where the
satisfaction within this Ward
particularly bear in mind that the
consultation had 3,000 people objecting
to na3 maybe 12 in favor of it and that
dissatisfaction had an audience no one
starts a website that doesn't have an
audience it was a website by which we
sort of through lyrical petrol bombs at
the council and yes we all had a lot of
fun and that was that people said to me
well it's all very well doing that isn't
it but could you do any better and I
thought about that and I thought well I
think May
we could do better so as joining the
council was the means by which we set
aside those weapons and tried to engage
in a real way with the council and tried
to make a change now that is what we
tried to do and I think that people
coming in from the cold like that is
something that any democratic
institution should try and encourage
that is what we did to keep going back
to the NSN website and trying to attach
rooted doors to it I think is very very
cynical and it is very very a very poor
faith so I think we should put the NSN
website to one side strategy and not
mention it again please
can I just say something can Salome
thank you for the clarity on that on who
set up the website and we we do know
that councillor Dawes was working in a
private capacity and not a counselor
when he joined you on that website so we
fully understand that sorry sorry you
just said I joined him on the website he
said very clearly I've never had
anything to do with it hmm so you're
you're saying that you had nothing to do
with the website at all Council Liam
Malone just said very clearly he said he
had nothing to do with the website he
met me through the website he messaged
me through the website and message I met
him thank you very much thanks for the
clarity on that thank you
so know that it's relevant okay council
hangs you wish to come back well yes I
mean that and obviously become clear
once we read through the report you know
the point is when the complaints are
originally made by individuals they
wouldn't know who was or wasn't
responsible for it we've established now
already reading through the report we've
had a confirmation statement that
councillor doors wasn't but you have to
have it investigated before you can
actually come to that conclusion and
what we're doing is going through the
investigation so didn't mean to dwell on
it now or any point Hereafter I think
it's just wasting members time oh sorry
a point of order but I think your most
work wasting members time because as
Haslam alone my investigator
isn't relevant you're bringing the late
cemetery why we are raking over these
coals I have no idea mother you've
brought it up because everybody else
keeps bringing it up well we don't need
to keep bringing it up that's my point
chairman we've accepted arranged had to
be litigated because of the complaint
now we would like to move on move on can
i clarify the absolute doors no we would
like to move on no I'd like to say we
don't want to talk about it and you're
wasting my time now
Enochs you know that's be my counselor
we are moving on to six point one seven
six point two seven members briefing on
climate change there's three breaches
that the investigator is hinted at is
there any questions or comments that you
wish to have counts the doors on that
yes that only that they're not
substantiated by the evidence of the
reports okay do I have any questions
from counselors counsel alone you still
have your blue hand up and counselor
hangs you still have your blue handle
please okay no further questions six
point two eight to six point three for
Facebook post 24th of September
any comments counselor doors
yes
in terms of 6.32 this is know England
misleading this this again says illegal
offs that are confirms him the briefing
was not required to be open to the
public by the local government under the
local government night I'd like evidence
to be provided because the only
information I had was when I raised the
complaints against bill she is I was
puzzled under investigation and they was
explained in that email rather crossly
why he wasn't open to the public
okay thank you moving on I have no
further questions from councillors six
point three five two six point four two
email to Michelle Luscombe of 21st of
October do you have any comments to make
on that council doors yes yes I mean the
as has been represented by the support
from the wolf of residents association
and Abbot's Kerswell Parish Council I
was lack elected because the vast number
of residents didn't agree with the basis
of the local plan talking about your
conduct again councillor doors I I know
but there is as I think has been stated
there was nothing wrong with my email
that I puts in Michelle Luskin on that
date I think that's included any
councillors wish to question that
okay no further questions six point four
three two six point five six protocol on
member officer relationship do you have
anything to say on that counselor doors
yeah six point six point five two which
indicates that counselor doors behavior
would not be considered appropriate by
the council this I believe is misleading
as one of those statements than is made
we don't basis okay any questions from
counselors on counselor doors or the
investigator on that no that's all I
have but I will will now ask counselor
doors if he would like to round up if
there's anything that you'd like to say
all I needs to I did have a note I I had
notes all the this summaries of findings
and I will rounding up as well versions
please go ahead
yeah so I wait yes yes sorry sorry I was
just finding finding the relevant
documents so 7.2 in making his public
accusation of accusation of misfits in
public office he was disrespectful to
the managing director the report and
investigates have consistently knowingly
misled the stone misleading the
standards committee is a tremely a
communication there is neither public
nor an accusation been given in Kevin
ill statement it can be understood how'd
that conclusion an opinion may be formed
7.3 the counselor doors was
disrespectful to the managing director
and failed to follow paragraph 1 the
investigated wording consistently shown
to be knowingly misleading
challenging sell shares own no they
argued something and change that into an
argument on no basis
he cannot demonstrate that have occurred
the next point that he was threatening
and intimidating to the managing
director
the investigators world's had
consistently shown to be knowingly
misleading changing filling his note
again the next point counselor doors
brought the council into disrepute and
for the offense for the four point seven
again consistently miss misleading and
the investigator cannot demonstrate it
so conclude I will provide a document
with the full rebuttals including
several appendices that have the email
chains that we've discussed the
investigations been carried out by Tim
Darlie among with no formal investing
like the investigate be did
qualifications difficult for me to say
the report is flawed and knowingly and
misleading throughout team Bruce
District Council brought this forward on
the basis of no complaints I believe
it's politically motivated I believe
it's undemocratic teamriche District
Council have also failed in their legal
obligations have supplied both me and
Lee Malone with our freedom of
information request they defend our
positions and carry out our roles as
elected members in the eyes of the
public in the eyes of the person on the
street other scenes have been acting in
the very best interests of them and
acting in the public interest Newton
says no has been painted as a pantomime
villain and the case embarrassingly
tries to find me guilty by association
if providing scrutiny and demanding
transparency is disrespectful in the
eyes of TVC then I'm sorry that's the
basis of democracy irrespective of the
outcome I intense take a buy some what
actions may be appropriate against in
DARS Lee and against increased assistant
counsel persist proceeding with this
case it will be a turn of phase to meet
the high bar of mystery ins in public
office we've no idea whether we to get
there but it may well do at the very
least TVC has proved to myself and the
electric
and the electorate in the residence of
team rates that the senior management
are indeed out of control and acting on
the edge of democratic process thank you
very much okay counselor does any
questions from counselors to counselor
Mike Haynes Sharon councillor Dawes said
he was going to send us further
documentation given that he knew that we
were deliberating everything today I
just wondered why that documentation
hadn't been sent in the thoughts so we'd
have an opportunity to read it is his
castle doors it's not that lengthy it is
a summary of what has been said today
and then the documents to back that I
did say at the very outset of this that
when we were put under investigation
I wanted transparency and I would only
engage in this process when he was fully
in the public domain as of 10:30 today
it became a matter of public record in
the public domain
I will thus provide my document with the
comments that I've raised and the
concerns I've raised today
I believe the committee has seven days
to consider their position I think you
should consider Katz very carefully over
that seven-day period thank you for that
capsule doors Castle Malone you've got a
blue hand up do you wish to say anything
yeah I just I'd like to make a sort of
version of a closing statement and
cancel Malone it's not for you to make a
closing statement it is you're not
repeating I won't be repeating though
okay ahead in terms of councilor doors
and as I've said before I haven't known
him for very long but he is probably the
most respectful person I know he is a
stickler for law and for process and for
things to be done properly and I think
that is a lot of where the conflict is
coming from here frankly especially when
it comes to things such as a witness
statement submitted 292 days late
that to him seemed unfair and
unreasonable and would to any reasonable
person that statement doesn't have a
single date on it doesn't have a single
time it is written with its extreme lack
of professionalism my nine year old
twins could write a better record than
mr. darcy's and why is employed by this
council I have no idea
now we represent the the NS n represents
the the opinions of hundreds and
thousands of councillors we didn't
squeak into our seats they elected as
for a purpose and that's to hold this
council to account we have done that
that was our promise to them and that is
what is absolutely sacrosanct to us if
that brings us into conflict with the
council then I put it to you that there
may be something wrong with the
operations of the council that's all I
have to say thank you Thank You counsel
Malone independent person you wish to
speak please on mute
yeah thank you Thank You chair and
question four comes with dolls and
you've just had a excellent reference
made to you from Connor Malone saying
you're a stickler for law and process
what I'd be interested to hear your view
or just take this as a statement really
when you were had two members of the
public with you a problem to the front
door of the council offices and it was
locked
thinking there may have been public
access I would have thought perhaps I'll
have to wait or there is no public
access as it's five to nine did it seem
appropriate then to go around to a side
entrance and let these people in to the
council offices on your path and further
introduce them to the building which in
these days of security importance I
expect I I don't know you but if you are
a professional person there must be
security perhaps in your offices
what term what would you what would you
say or say to something who Dan carried
oh it could be said even a malicious
acts acts to people to get them into the
building on your path that's that's a
very interesting question I don't
believe that I'm being charged with
breach of conduct for that but but I'll
answer it nonetheless because it raises
some very interesting points the the
reason that I brought them into the
building because in good faith I still
believe that Gordon hook would be able
to open up the public gallery and that
it is in the public interest did I think
it was a risk you talk about my
professional life III rom venues I I
look after the safety of thousands and
thousands of members of the public in
very difficult situations I understand
risk assessments I understand the legal
responsibilities of those I assess the
risk I knew both individuals are married
to one of them and I was acting in the
best interest of the public there was no
risk in the slightest to paint into an
area that was in five minutes time going
to be open to the public
thank you very much councillor doors
council mellow and you put something on
the screen there you're welcome to speak
you don't have to hold a bit of paper up
it's the canvas or a public building I
think that's something we need to bear
in mind thank you any further questions
from the committee
yes um yes it's a question to Richard or
counselor Richard doors good morning to
you regarding the climate meeting
whereby we have been advised that the
notification was sent out six weeks
prior to the date it was being held was
there any specific reason why you did
not raise the question and it being a
public meeting
um up until only a week before yes the
reason I raised it a week before is
because I was raising a question for the
full council meeting that happened an
hour afterwards I knew that based on the
question that I was raising that we
would have a full public gallery
I noticed that I'd been sent this very
important briefing note that was in the
public building an expert from X the
University come in to tell us about the
single most important issue in our time
in a public building for a public body
it was perfectly reasonable at that
juncture for me to have the enlightened
moment to think hey wouldn't it be great
if all those people are going to be
coming an hour later could us you come
to this as well and learn something and
be informed and and I put that to the
leader of the council and he agreed with
me as did the full executive I had the
full backing of Gordon Hogue and the
full executive and their their
frustration at the end of the day is
that the managing director for know Reno
good reasons were given kept people out
of the briefing in a in a public
building that they could easily be
easily been let into thank you
Thank You councillor doors how do you
further questions councilor Patrick just
a final one really I mean you know I
accept you fight hard for your
constituencies and you're doing exactly
what you were elected to do but you you
have no acknowledgement of how some of
your words have affected some of the
officers and you seem to have no
acknowledgement of that so are you
saying you haven't been rude to people
and intimidated them and made them feel
frightened yeah that's correct I think
you're confusing when you say some of my
words could you actually give me
some of the words you're talking about
because my Reports has been colored by
things that have no relationship to me
and I have no responsibility for it's a
pure pantomime I'm guilty by association
and unfortunately Linda you you are
repeating back things that were put in
the record design to create the
emotional response that you've got by
associating me with the actions of
others I think some of its around what
you said - Michelle and some of the
things that were said to Michelle in and
the fact that she said she was almost
frightened to go to her house I think
you're talking about my report documents
probably so that you can take a proper
part in this discussion the report
relating to this if counselor dort is
telling me it's not right and then I
will listen so so the only communication
I have with Michelle Luscombe in the
report relates to a local plan meeting
the new and I would you to go to is the
first one I can make it for family
reasons and I because I can make it for
family reasons I asked the WR Rae and a
PC if there was anything that they
thought I should put forward that was
reasonable as there's an opening salvo
of where they thought the local plan was
and their position is it wasn't done
right in the first place I said those
words I don't think those words would
make someone frightened to go to their
house it is a
an honest opinion from representative
bodies who I was elected to voice in a
democratic manner
I do think within this you you are
confusing me and my actions and the the
responsive Michelle as soon as she's put
forward the I don't believe in my report
she said she was scared too and go to a
house because of my actions I think it
was around a meeting at the wall breath
the walbro meeting ok can you point me
in the that that was the points at the
report that says that did warbird EBD I
don't believe the I had anything to do
with any posts that were made the the
would have made I'm happy to you won't
find it because it's not there
Thank You councilman the report they
shouldn't be in the meeting stay
completely dissed Thank You counselors
Thank You counselors and I refer you to
6.35 email Michelle Luscombe of 21st of
October so we all have read this report
many times over I think I've read it at
least four times and picked out pieces
and I thank counselors is there any
further questions from counselors
counselor doors is there anything
further that you wish to add to this
committee and please be mindful if
you're sending any information to us we
need to have it today we need to have it
before we should have had it before the
meeting but we certainly need to have it
immediately after this meeting I think
within the confidentiality rules that we
were trying to understand
I think he's understanding was there
until it was out there they couldn't be
broadcast I think that's what happened
now no we could read it beforehand
you know I'd be quite happy to read
anything that you you
sent to us I'm happy with that I've been
clear why why I did not want to engage
in this process because I believe in
transparency I once it I've been told
for a very long time this is
confidential and there's something I
failed to understand why I'm acting in
the public interest
I was rather in be transparent I said I
would engage with the process when it
was in a public domain it is now I hope
you feel that you've had your chance to
voice your opinion and defend yourself
in this committee hearing am I correct
in that yeah I've just friendly the 6.37
the officer told me the email raised the
working group felt the language language
use was an acceptable
she didn't regard council endorses
comments as person to her the comments I
used were it wasn't them right in the
first time I stand by them Richard yes
yes I did I do feel other than the fact
I wasn't able to get through the woman
residents association warm page well no
you can send that to the members of this
committee and we'll read it and I'm
happy to put that on out publicly as as
I have done with the full report and I
made that decision early on and we want
transparency here we want to hear what
you've got to say we want to hear what
everyone else has got to say but most
importantly it's this committee that
decides are you okay with all that I I'm
okay with that
I mean I think I will continue to carry
out my duties as a council and I'll
continue to I think we all do that
councillor doors day-in day-out one
final one final thing I have for you is
that on the 1st of November
2019 this is my closing statement you
were invited to a meeting to discuss the
concerns that we've all heard about and
you declared it wasn't possible to go to
that meeting to resolve this back in
November 2009 team first of November yes
and with the monitoring officer yes
that's correct
all right
okay wait to explain why now you've
raced it yeah yes that's pushing yeah
the the reason I I i felt compromised in
that is that because i the full
executive and many of the public felt
that the meeting should have been open
to the public the climate change meeting
should have been open to the public I
raised a complaint against the managing
director because he hadn't in my view
followed the Local Government Act 1972
to allow the meeting to be open to the
public the reply that I got was that I
had breached though there were many
concerns about me essentially I was
going to be put under investigation what
I felt was that because I raised
concerns I was being bullied and
intimidating in return basically saying
please don't question us you don't
you're not in the position to do that I
don't think that's reasonable I was not
willing to engage in that I still don't
know why several complaints are put in
just similarly get ignored by the
monitoring officer I have another one
that I will restate and if I can't put
the Mint's of team Bruce District
Council I will place them elsewhere okay
so in 1.6 I'll come back to this in 1.6
you were invited to discuss the concerns
this was prior to the report so if you'd
have discussed this with the monitoring
officer at this point we wouldn't be
here now
we wouldn't be have this report before
us and we would you would have dealt
with this at that meeting with the
monitoring officer but you refused to
resolve these these issues that we know
how before is that's why today but if
these are breaches of conduct then
aren't you you would have carried on I'm
sure the process would have carried on
if I turned up to Karen's Ricky's office
and said yes I do think that the I held
the view that there's been miss feelings
in public office is that no no no that's
not what we're here to discuss we're
here to discuss your conduct and if I
can be straightforward to you again I
put it to you that eat on the first of
November you were written to eat
in the report 1.6 and that was inviting
you to discuss the concerns and that
would point would you like it is already
part of my appendix that communication
is the final communication in relation
to the climate change exchange you will
be all the committee will be able to see
that email and my response to it but one
point six states caps the doors that it
was to resolve all oh not just that one
about the climate change in the accessed
you know that it's your conduct that
we're here I know I know and I've
consistently asked if anyone's got a
formal complaints against me could they
make it could I know who's made the
complaint could I have the wording of
the complaint that is why I put the
Freedom of Information request and
subject access requests which the
council has not carried out his legal
duties to provide well the council has
provided you with the 57 page document
that's already that's that's a report
oh yes last-minute additions yeah yeah
yes it has a cost and five thousand
pounds that the taxpayer yes which could
have been resolved in 1.6 I don't
believe he couldn't know on the first of
November 2019 so you remind to come to a
meeting with a monitoring office you're
suggesting I would go to the meeting and
all the things that are that the the
committee now are considering and the
the investigator agree sir I've reached
the code of conducts III can test those
I would have still contested those by
contestant now I would have contested
them at the meeting okay thank you
counselor doors any further questions
from counselors counselor paths right
you still have your blue hand up nope no
any further questions from the committee
two counts the doors or the
investigating nope
Council Malone you still have your blue
hand up I didn't realize I did but since
I did yeah I have a question how do you
think this looks to people to reasonable
people I think and I hope mr. 292 days
late
if you keep speaking out I can't answer
gates to be this slapdash if you e this
if you can let me see even in your
application of your own rules how do you
think this looks to people if you
collect this pin spelling counsel into
disrepute do you see how disrepute
accumulates it accumulates through me
Thank You counselor Malone something can
I say something
thank you thank you very much thank you
counselors fewer attendance today and
thank you for your comments and we will
now consider the matter please press
your leave button thank you
you